feel like the big theme of this season
is that emily
is really facing issues of fame
and notoriety and does she want it does
she not want it
how would you kind of describe her
journey that she goes on in season two
i mean the journey is trying to find and
those uh the answers to those questions
that you sort of just threw out there
it's you know
what's gonna happen if i if my life goes
from being the corner of my bedroom at
this tiny desk
with one reader right of my poems
to possibly the world
emily again is searching for the answers
to
what is fame exactly i don't want to
disappear from this earth without
anybody knowing who i am
what is the meaning of that what
determines that
am i opening myself up to a world of
judgment and all this sort of self-doubt
comes over her
she's never ever had an issue with
sitting down and writing and suddenly
she's just like overtaken and consumed
by this idea of
of fame and attention and it's something
she's always thought
she wanted um and and we sort of imagine
that like that's something she's
she must want right sometimes when i
write i lose control
you're about to become world famous
overnight and so it's just sort of this
crazy back and forth rollercoaster right
of her trying to figure out what the
heck she really wants
do you at all relate to her struggles
with
i don't know if i necessarily relate to
her struggles
but i did find myself um
challenged this season in in finding the
answers to these questions because i'd
never really asked myself them before
fame is never really something i have
felt like i've had to deal with
i've accepted it for what it is it kind
of comes with the territory i just feel
so lucky i get to do what i love i found
myself like
not having the answers to a lot of the
questions she was looking for therefore
just made me think about it in ways i
hadn't before
only huge open party looking like a
wreck
i'm not here for the party fans love and
also i love
emily and sue's relationship yeah of
course now we have sue
and she's married how do you feel like
we're gonna see their relationship
play out in season two or how would you
describe their relationship and see
oh it's messy and it's heartbreaking and
it's beautiful
and um confusing
uh sue has had quite the transformation
between season one and season two and
you know
we sort of pick up with them in a place
where sue is living this life
where she's just kind of deflecting um
suddenly she's gone from wearing one
color to wearing every color
being introverted to you know
making people think that she's now
extroverted she's throwing these parties
but she's really deep down dealing with
what we find out in season two um
and she's pushing emily away from her
and and emily is confused and feels like
well the reason she's there's a good
reason behind it but but
do i trust her intentions and but their
relationship is is
as complicated and as beautiful as ever
in season two so i'm i'm really excited
to
watch people watch it play what did you
think of my poems tell me
i loved them how would you say that
season two is
sexier than season one our characters
are now in their
mid-20s and um they're just
in a different light this whole season
is elevated and
and the scope of it feels so much bigger
uh
and there are things that we get into
this season that um
we sort of maybe touched on in season
one and we go there this time
part of me is pretty sure that fame
isn't good for me
in fact i think it could be very
dangerous what is it like going from
a period comedy to an action-packed
hawkeye set where you play kate bishop
it couldn't be more different um but
it's uh it's it's a fun change of pace i
just i love
what i do so much for that reason i i'm
in one world one day and a completely
different one the next um
but it's been so fun to have this
opportunity creatively
and just having lived in this world of
dickinson that i'm so thankful i get the
opportunity to go back to
because i get to take a step back and
think you know in my own time
just obviously about the character and
about the progression of things
um and to be able to walk away and sort
of
enter a new headspace and then come back
with with a fresh
outlook um i feel like is is just
amazing as an artist to have the
opportunity to do to do that but i'm i'm
honored to be involved in both projects
what
about kate are you excited to bring to
the screen
without your virginal surprise fans you
know
oh i mean i i
i'm just so excited as i am in the
process of developing her
i'm working with some incredible
filmmakers that are helping me bring her
to life
i can't wait for people just to see how
we are interpreting this character
through the comics um
and and in our own sort of ways she's
such a badass there's no denying that
she's so smart and witty and quick and
um her physical ability
to do so many things is through the roof
it's really
it's tested me and it's kept me uh going
through quarantine i will say it's given
me a reason to
stay with it um but i'm just uh very
excited as i continue developing her
um to see sort of how we come up with it
you